okay we have been challenged to describe
our new movie marvel studios shanxi and
the legend of the ten rings without
saying certain words we're gonna quiz
each other and then if we say the words
that we're not supposed to say guess
what
if they hear this annoying buzzer sound
let's do it you got this thank you
all right steven you ready absolutely
not describe what the movie is about
without using the words superhero 10 and
rings okay um so the movie's about a a
guy whose father is the leader of a
criminal organization and he raises a
son who's one of the greatest
hand-to-hand fighters you know ever the
son was like no dad i don't want to do
that anymore and he starts a new life in
america and then certain events
transpire and he gets brought back into
the world of the criminal organization
all right thank you thank you love that
guy round number two monger describe
your character sally without using the
words daughter sister or fighter she is
shanxi's father's other child oh
okay wait what and she is really good at
martial arts and she
kicked everyone's butts i'd watch that
movie aquafina describe your character
and her relationship to shanghi without
the words best
friend san francisco well my name is
katie and i
hang out with zhang ji in the city where
you leave your heart in i
have a fanny pack
excellent well i think we all won that
round
we make a good team
simu describe shang chi's powers without
using the words martial arts fighting or
assassin ready
he punches people real good
next question
monger
describe the character of wenwu without
using the words father rings
bad guy he is not
a very good guy whoa oh guys
oh god okay
tell people why they should go see this
film without using the words
marvel
amazing action-packed
humans
interacting
with humans
who are you that's a 10 out of 10.
make sure to go see marvel studios
chiang chi in the ledge of the ten rings
now playing